du hast dich mit dem thema was gestern
in der demokratie passiert ist im
weitesten sinne auseinandergesetzt sind
viele haben gesagt dass soziale
netzwerke am ende für größere demokratie
gesagt okay
okay übergang habe das ist ja das schöne
wir sagen jetzt sehen wir auch vorher
nicht so genau deswegen kommen beim
thema jetzt mal eine sache möchte ich
aber noch von meiner sendezeit die da
habe ich ja frei nutzen noch ergänzend
zu der debatte gerade in deutschland
krankt an so ein berufspolitiker nur
ganz böse foul
weil wir noch mal nein ein höherer
politik halten sagt die eine flasche
sind die andere mit hoch politiker
während politik wäre wie ein flaschenzug
das wollte ich nur noch ergänzen jetzt
bekommen wir aber nicht meinem zimmer
das thema ist nämlich facebook und
instagram und twitter aber es wird ja
weniger weil das war gestern auch online
sondern vor allem facebook und zwar weil
der konzern facebook gestern tot ins
schwimmbad trotz etwa tod nichts gegen
mehr facebook war dann konnte das
natürlich sehen als etwas ganz schlimmes
was gerade passiert ist für den facebook
konzern die aktie war auch im rausch
nach unten hier sehen wir silicon valley
das headquarter von facebook ich war mal
da 2018 weil ich drei wochen als
wirtschaftsjournalistin auch im silicon
valley unterwegs sind da kann man
facebook schon merkwürdig vor dieser
campus es kam mir alles so
sektenähnliche aufwenden hartes wort ist
auf jeden fall gruppen die gruppen liebe
hat man sehr gemerkt zu facebook gestern
war es dann aber anstatt sich zu
beschweren haben sehr viele stars
gepostet wie zum beispiel christi taken
sie hat geschrieben alles ist da und
wirklich lebt uns das wird alles weg und
wer ist dieser mysteriöse hält teils
scherzhaft aber teils zu recht haben
eigentlich prominente und auch
wissenschaftler auf twitter kann das war
noch die plattform die online war darauf
hingewiesen dass facebook gefährlich ist
und facebook ist auch gefährlich selbst
facebook mitarbeiter die meisten
facebook tätig waren warnen vor dem
konzern sie warnen vor der macht vor
allem waren sie von der plattform
institut instagram soll laut studien so
gefährlich seien die alkohol und
zigaretten auch facebook führt seit
jahren stand geheime studien durch wie
hoch jetzt wirklich der psychologischen
schaden durch die benutzung von
instagram ist nur eine studie studien
sind ja meist langweilig eine für mich
aber schon sehr wichtig jedes dritte
mädchen das instrument benutzt und im
jugendalter ist entwickelten körperbild
was nicht positiv ist sondern nimmt sich
immer wieder heran und meint sie müsse
so aussehen also ein negatives
körperbild wirklich instagram von mitte
depressionen werden ausgelöst er sitzt
ein psychologen im silicon valley die
darauf konditioniert dich oder mich nur
darauf konditioniert desto länger dort
zeit verbringst für mich war also
gestern dieser shutdown von facebook
eigentlich die einladung dass wir alle
vielleicht mehr darüber sprechen sollten
wie viel macht der konzern haben sollte
und ob es nicht vielleicht sogar gut
wäre wenn man die sozialen medien
weniger nutzen darüber sprechen weniger
nutzen finde ich alles okay ich fand das
klang jetzt schon so ein bisschen so als
sollten wir darüber reden auch irgendwie
staatlich was zu tun also dein appel das
finde ich dann gefährlich ehrlich gesagt
wenn wir über irgendwelche art von
verboten sprechen und wenn du die stars
ansprichst die da gestern alle gepostet
haben das sind ja wohl die allergrößten
optimisten die da draußen rumlaufen also
wenn facebook in estern posten wie
facebook wird instagram innes instagram
und wenn es da ist dann gehen sie auf
einen anderen kanal und sagen aus alles
ganz schlimm da drüben die wollen doch
nur noch mehr aufmerksamkeit also ich
glaube du bist da auf diese stars am
ende reingefallen und noch etwas ist wir
haben nicht und ich finde dass soziale
netzwerke man das nicht nur darauf
konzentrieren darf was wir hier in
deutschland für erfahrungen gemacht
haben oder die stars für erfahrung
gemacht haben ich habe gemerkt in vielen
regionen aus denen ich berichtet haben
in den vergangenen jahren insbesondere
die arabische welt als ist die
revolution dort die gescheiterte muss
man letztendlich sagen gab 2010 und auch
viele andere dass soziale medien den
unterdrückten stimmen eine so wichtige
stimme gegeben haben dass ich finde dass
es gar nicht genug und sozialer medien
geben darf also erstmal nur kurz agenten
staatlichen eingriff will ich natürlich
nicht ich glaube es gibt keine größere
freiheitskämpferin es mich und ich will
dass die wirtschaft die politik ist nur
setzt nur die rahmenbedingungen die
wirtschaft ist in jedem land der motor
und amerika ist ja auch stolz auf diesen
digital konzern der von mark zuckerberg
aus dem studentenzimmer erfunden wurde
und natürlich ein riesiges
wirtschaftsunternehmen ist weil sich
aberglaube ist zb unsere digitalen
ministerin dorothea hat auf insgesamt
stehen installieren und da muss ich
schon sagen ich liebe es war nicht fax
ministerin ich erwarte paar von
politikern dass sie schon darauf
hinweisen zum beispiel bei zigaretten
überall ist der bahn hinweis darauf
schade der gesundheit ja so ich rauche
trotzdem gerne abends mal wenn ich mir
das weinen dringenden zigarette ist blöd
weil sich selber auch ich mache aber und
ich möchte aber dass bei instagram
darauf hingewiesen wird dass es
schädlich ist und mir wird darüber zu
wenig geredet und ich glaube dass wir
die studien wirklich nicht einfach außer
acht lassen für sollten und sagen na ja
wenn jungen mädchen psychische probleme
haben dann ist es ja halt so man muss
wirklich sagen dass vor allem diese
filter schlimm sind für die entwicklung
von jungfrau alexander kissler bronze
warnhinweise bei instagram nicht
benutzten gefährlich macht süchtig macht
so sich die in zigaretten zu hören dass
england das war ich noch mal sagen ja
hab ich gerne aber selbst als
nichtraucher der ich aber ästhet bin
stören mich hat diese warnhinweise schon
bei den zigaretten dass ich also hat
auch geduld eine aufgeschnittene lungen
sehe und blutgerinnsel es macht
inkompetent impotent was auch immer das
finde ich schon sehr übergriffig wer
nutzen digitale medien menschen menschen
die hoffentlich mündig sind und die wenn
sie nicht mündig sind hoffentlich zur
mündigkeit erzogen wenn wir brauchen
also digitale bildung aber keine
digitalen zensur debatten jährt sich das
anschaut muss selbst in der lage sein zu
beurteilen ist als wirklichkeit oder ein
schrecklich entstellen das bild in
wirklichkeit haben nach meiner
entwicklung nicht gut hass ist nach auch
wirklich viel stärker bauen als wird
durch einen warnhinweis vorsicht die
wirklichkeit ist ganz anders davon halte
ich nichts also das ist ja ein sehr ich
weiß ich meinen sie sind zwar xe
schweizer aber oder oder der
importierter schweiz habe aber sie haben
die doppelte freiheitsliebe
wahrscheinlich mitgenommen aus diesem
land wunderbares land das ist ja eine
ganz schräge diskussion denn wir wissen
doch wirklich bei instagram sind es
viele viele kinder viele junge mädchen
die auf diesem netzwerk sind tik tok
sollte man nicht vergessen im übrigen
die stunden und stunden um stunden dort
verbringen und sie sagen jetzt dass
müssen mündige menschen sein das
entspricht da überhaupt nicht das ist
doch einer gesellschaft instagram sieht
wie ein dopamin kick und entsprechend
langsam aber sicher nach hause von
diskussionen die gesehen haben dass
während unserer kompanie die menschen
immer mehr viele kinder auch immer mehr
sich verloren haben in sozialen kann man
nicht hergehen und sagen das ist die
freiheit die ich mir gehalten hatte und
natürlich wird aber kein problem gelöst
wenn ich hinweise machen also wenn der
staat wenn ich alles machen wie man
einmal muss über eine lösung wäre zum
beispiel wie bei einem führerschein man
muss sich mit seinem ausweis anmelden
dann wird sich so viel fake accounts
geben das problem ist aber facebook will
genau diese inhalte facebooken möchte
die inhalte die negativ sind bei
facebook ist die bloggerin hat gestern
ausgepackt wie facebook ist auch wut
konzentriert facebook hat gemerkt gut
funktioniert am besten und
dementsprechend wird auch darauf
konditioniert und nach acht ja auch
nicht schlecht die wut
der einzigen gäste er ist ja völlig
untergegangen als wäre es ein großer
zufall dass parallel ebendieser
und dann auf einmal den auftritt dort
weil die wii ist 7.30 habe
zwar zwei jahre bei facebook hat genau
aufgeschlüsselt bei ihrer anhörung sei
eben diese hasserfüllten hast kommentare
eben sich immer weiter potenziert und
von facebook auch durch entsprechende
algorithmen gezeigt was bist du
instagram süchtig oder facebook süchtig
oder irgendwann da hinein nicht 480
design also instagram bin ich nicht so
darauf mein sohn ist dabei tik tok und
so aber nein es wissen wir schon
aufpassen dass wir nicht im falschen
film land eine entschuldigung kam ich
kann mich nicht erinnern ich habe das
gelesen bei der erfindung des
staubsaugers und des kühlschranks gab es
auch eine riesen debatte in den usa wo
die kühlschränke verbinden sollte oder
die staubsauger neue technologien haben
die möglichkeit dass man sie gut oder
schlecht nutzen kann aber dieses verbots
zeug da das bringt dann gar nichts weil
die kinder machen das dann sowieso das
spielte keine rolle und ich halte hier
natürlich auch ganz klar dagegen
ich finde es ist schlecht was bei
facebook läuft auch mit dieser zensur
das jetzt angefangen habe nach bei
youtube sachen zu zensurieren roche
tattoo day all diese bevormundung das
alles den die schlecht finde ich nicht
gut aber am ende des tages teile ich die
these von paul ronzheimer diese sozialen
netzwerke haben die welt zu einem
besseren ort gemacht die haben die
diskussion für vielfältig sie haben
natürlich jetzt auch sehr starken
politischen einfluss und ich meine man
muss versuchen hier den politischen
einfluss wieder raus zu drängen in die
mündigkeit zu vertrauen auch in die
verantwortung der eltern das ist nämlich
auch eine abnahme der verantwortung der
eltern wenn man plötzlich sagt man muss
ist dieses zeug daraus verbieten und
diese social networks darum haben die
ach so viel kohle verdient das sind
geniale erfindungen die wieder
staubsaugen und wieder kühlschrank und
wie das alles miteinander zu
zwei erfunden diese glorreiche deutsche
finanz glatte was darf im artikel
erschienen sind die bild zeitung gab es
noch nicht aber ein paar und jetzt kommt
die höllenmaschine die teufel zu
maschinen und ich weiß nicht was
umgebracht das relax entspannt euch
diese social media sind gut aber je mehr
die politik dar ein punkt bin ich bei
kessler desto schlechter kommt heraus
bin entsetzt dass sie jetzt plötzlich
die nähmaschine zu anwältinnen der
unfreiheit war ihre
unterstützung zur seite von einer
handlung zu sehen wir den studien
in anderen social media art ausgeht ihr
geht von der politisierten social media
aus wo ihr eure erfahrung weil wir all
unsere erfahrungen und erkenntnisse
erholen aus aktuellen anlässen wo auf
twitter natürlich und aus allen regionen
der welt die neuesten erkenntnisse da
sind und tratsch wir reden hier über den
instrument für 14-jährige 16 jährige
mädchen aber jemand im moment von von
rosen ich richtig müssen da nicht die
eltern einschreiten und sagen so wie
früher weil sie nun als ich mit den fans
gespielt habe und so viel vielfalt ist
ein alle meine mama irgendwann gesagt
hat drei stunden ist jetzt mal stärken
aber zweifeln weil die kinder gegen
seine teamkollegen kein tipp ich bin in
herford und habe mich letzte mit einem
sehr erfahrenen lehrern über das thema
und traut und weißt du was man als
eltern machen muss wenn die kinder zu
stark in diesen welten network sind
nicht mit verboten und mit der peitsche
kommen sondern du musst versuchen die
kinder auch ihr vertrauen zu gewinnen
dass du ihnen sagen kannst tschuldigung
du kommst nicht stundenlang darauf sein
du musst versuchen auch den respekt
eines kind zu behalten wenn man einfach
mit verboten kommt das ist die erfahrung
dann machen sie sowieso
[Musik]